All right! You're done.
Let's take a look at my solution.
All right. So, here's what
our addLocation function looks like.
locationSetting, cityName,
latitude, and longitude.
Just like in our content provider test,
we can use getContentResolver
to query based upon the content URI.
Remember that the default
location entry CONTENT_URI
passes all of the parameters
into the database.
So we can easily construct a query
containing the location setting
to see if it's in the database yet.
If it's not, then the query
will return an empty set
and we should insert
the new city name, location setting,
latitude, and longitude
into the database together.